in Chicago Dr Martin Steiner and his
team of scientists are experimenting
with a large particle collider machine
when it suddenly goes into a meltdown
this causes a deadly explosion resulting
in widespread Devastation hundreds and
thousands of people are instantly killed
while millions of others are injured in
the aftermath of this event Chicago is
sealed from all sides and declared a
noggo Zone however strange ghosts
suddenly start showing up here and there
labeled as remnants they are the
projections of the people who died in
the explosion while they appear to be
exactly like their true forms they
cannot alter the reality and hence are
of no threat to the living people the
remnants only last for a few seconds and
their actions are carried out in a loop
this means that a Remnant riding a
bicycle today will be doing the same
thing tomorrow hopefully none of these
remnants last moments we're spent
jurking the girkin the movie then cuts
to 10 years later and we are taken to a
town just outside Chicago even here many
people were killed by the explosion and
their remnants are appearing on a daily
basis we are then introduced to Veronica
Calder a 17-year-old girl who lives with
her mom Anna her dad was also one of the
victims from that fateful day and he now
shows up every morning for breakfast in
his Remnant form at school the physics
teacher August Bitner is giving a speech
about the remnants Veronica curiously
asks why dead people from other
timelines are turning into remnants as
of late she gives an example by pointing
towards a girl who is clearly dressed in
80s attire however Bitner doesn't have
an answer for this during lunchtime
Veronica has her gaze fixed on a guy
named Kirk who is antisocial and
obsessed with the remnants it is said
that he was kicked out of his previous
school but no one knows about the reason
that evening as Veronica is taking a
shower an unknown Remnant shows up out
of nowhere startling her then something
very creepy happens the mysterious
Remnant writes the word run on on the
mirror which is supposed to be
impossible because they are just
projections the following day a scared
Veronica approaches Bitner and says that
she wants to talk in private he agrees
and invites her over to his place on
arriving they come across his daughter
Eva but she acts cold and walks away
Veronica then explains the incident from
the other night which has left her
deeply unsettled however Bitner says
that it's impossible because the
remnants cannot affect the real world he
reasons that she must have suffered a
con cussion due to the fall which is
making her see things this teacher is
useless so far later Veronica decides to
seek help from Kirk as he knows a lot
about the entities she follows him to a
cave where hundreds of fish remnants are
swimming Kirk reveals that during the
rainy season this tunnel is usually
flooded and it supports a large number
of Aquatic Life he comes to this place
every day to observe the fish remnants
which seem to be growing in number this
means that the recently dead fish are
also turning into those those entities
one set of the tunnel Veronica gets
straight to the point and asks for his
help in identifying the mysterious
Remnant from her bathroom at first Kirk
refuses saying that he is busy but when
she promises to do his assignments for
him he agrees later at school as they
are brainstorming ways to find a
solution Veronica inadvertently calls
The Remnant Brian when asked how she
knows that name she has no answer Kirk
then says that for them to start the
research they need to take a picture of
Brian since ordinary cameras aren't
capable of doing that they will need a
spectrographic lens however the problem
is that these cost millions of dollars
fortunately Veronica has a friend who
can set up a makeshift spectrographic
lens using normal tools she should
probably monetize that says Kirk
the duo then installs the camera in the
bathroom and waits for Brian to arrive
after a while he shows up and the lens
appears to be affecting him he then
lunges at Veronica but at the same time
the lens shatters causing him to
disappear although it was a tense
encounter Kirk managed to capture a
picture of him he then does some
research and learns about Brian's
horrific past the following day at
school Kirk reveals to Veronica that
Brian was a serial killer who abducted
and murdered a local girl named Mary to
find more information they then visit
Mary's mother the latter says that Brian
stalked his daughter for weeks and
eventually persuaded her to come with
him that was the last time anyone saw
her alive she was found dead later that
night while Brian committed the
unthinkable the next day in the next
scene we see Veronica and Kirk
researching in the school library after
putting together all the clues they
discover that Mary was killed on her
birthday it was the 29th of February
also known as the leap year
coincidentally Veronica also has the
same birthday which makes her think if
all the events might be related as the
two are chatting a mysterious figure
appears behind them then the lights
start to Flicker and Veronica drops DRS
her book when she picks it up she finds
the word run scribbled several times
surely he could have used some of that
real estate to provide more detail the
following day Kirk is called to the
school office where the principal
inquires why he visited Mary's mother he
says that it was for an assignment but
the principal doesn't believe it
elsewhere we see Veronica at a
basketball game she tries to contact
Kirk desperately but he doesn't respond
simultaneously we see the principal
heading up the stairs after he receives
a text from someone at the basketball
court Veronica starts seeing the
mysterious Brian in various locations at
one point he stands on the other side of
the court so Veronica gets up from her
seat and tries to reach him she doesn't
even realize that she is interfering
with her play when she finally snaps out
of it something shocking happens the
principal suddenly falls through the
roof leaving everyone terrified later
Kirk visits Veronica at her house and
explains that he had told the principal
his entire theory he suspects that the
poor man was killed because of it
however Veronica believes that it was
just an accident as the two continue
chatting Kirk reveals that he started
researching the remnants because he
never got to say goodbye to his father
the latter suddenly passed away due to
the explosion and his Remnant has never
shown up so Kirk hopes that he can learn
more about the phenomenon and contact
his father someday that night Veronica
experiences an unsettling nightmare
where she sees Brian trying to grab her
she also experiences falling into an icy
lake where two female ghosts are
casually swimming when she wakes up Anna
enters her room and mentions that she
will be traveling to another city for a
job interview she will only be able to
return in 3 days this makes Veronica sad
as her mom is going to miss her birthday
and her birthday only happens once every
4 years later as the remnant Dad is
sitting in his usual breakfast position
Kirk notices something strange he sees
that the man is holding a newspaper
which was published 3 years after the
explosion took place the main headline
is about The Disappearance and murder of
two girls Emma and Claire Kirk quickly
notes down the details and begins
researching them he soon learns that
they also had their birthdays on the
29th of February and were killed on the
same day in the next scene the duo meets
an acquaintance who reveals that Brian
and CLA were in a relationship Clare
actually died in the same laboratory
from which the explosion originated her
death was so gruesome that many tourists
flocked to the lab to witness her
remnant's Recreation of the death
hearing this Veronica and Kirk are
perplexed and they wonder what Claire
and Brian were doing in the lab to find
more information they decide to head to
Chicago that evening they arrive at the
desolate city which has been completely
overrun by the remnants here the
entities last for hours and their
population is huge this is perhaps due
to the fact that Chicago is Ground Zero
and whatever is bringing the remnants
has more influence here ignoring this
the duo heads to the laboratory where
several people are witnessing cla's
Remnant in action the woman appears to
be scared and she climbs a set of
ladders possibly trying to escape
however she is caught and strangled
mercilessly just then Kirk notices Dr
Martin Steiner among the crowd and calls
out his name the latter who appears to
be living anonymously tries to flee the
scene but the two eventually catch up to
him they Grill him for an answers and he
reluctantly decides to speak up Martin
takes them to his main lab and explains
that when an explosion takes place a
dead person's Echo is Left Behind he
gives them an example by showing the
shadow of the deceased people left
behind by the Hiroshima and nasaki
victims Dr Martin explains that these
Echoes are a doorway that connects the
living people to the dead this part of
the story feels insensitive his team
used this Theory and treated numerous
people who were on the verge of death
however their main goal was to resurrect
a totally dead person for this they
needed a live person with the exact
birth date of the person they wanted to
reanimate the process was called
spectral transfusion however their
experiment was unsuccessful and it
resulted in the catastrophic explosion
that took many lives Dr Martin then
reveals that Brian was one of his
assistants who worked with him on the
project however when CLA was killed he
changed the doctor theorizes that Brian
killed the other victims with the same
birthday so that he could resurrect
Claire through spectral trans
meanwhile Kirk steals a photograph from
the lab so he can research it later it's
always research and stuff that boy Dr
Martin then confirms that whatever the
government is telling them is not true
the remnants can indeed alter the
present and they are a threat to the
living hearing all of this Veronica
wonders if Brian is trying to kill her
as she also shares the same February
29th birthday she tries to ask for more
information but the doctor who is
riddled with guilt abruptly commits the
unthinkable he's doing that now really
really in the next scene the duo returns
to the school to investigate further but
as soon as they arrive some officials
apprehend Kirk they have found a gun in
his locker desperate for help Veronica
approaches Bitner and explains the
entire situation luckily he believes her
this time as he has already talked to
Mary's mom and because it's about time
he did something he then reveals that
Brian was kicked out from his previous
school because they discovered a gun in
his locker there just like today this
makes Veronica suspicious of him so she
decides to ignore him from now on but
the problem isn't solved yet since the
29th of February is tomorrow Veronica
assumes that Brian is going to kill her
fortunately Bitner has a solution he
offers to design a special room in her
house where she can be safe this room
will be enclosed with lead lining which
apparently keeps the remnants out
Veronica knows that she doesn't have any
other options so she promptly agrees
meanwhile Anna reach es the said job
location but learns that no one had
called her someone actually played a
dirty prank on her that evening Kirk
pays Veronica a visit and tries to talk
to her but she acts cold out of
frustration he then reveals that he had
carried the gun in his previous school
to protect himself not to harm others
however he has no idea who placed the
gun in his locker yesterday still
Veronica doesn't want to talk so she
asks him to leave there the two work for
hours and finally design the special
room Veronica is asked to spend the
night there until the danger is over
meanwhile Kirk researches the picture he
took from the lab and makes a startling
Discovery it turns out that Bitner was
also one of the scientists in Dr
Martin's team this makes Kirk realize
that the man is up to something evil he
desperately tries to contact Veronica
but fails because of no network in the
room with no options there he rushes to
save her as soon as Kirk arrives outside
the house he notices bitner's daughter
Eva's Remnant this reveals that she is
not a real human after all following
this the movie goes into a flashback
where all the Mysteries are unraveled
during that fateful day Eva was also in
the laboratory and Bitner tried his best
to save her but failed due to her demise
he blamed himself day and night and
that's when he came up with the idea of
reanimating her using spectral trans
whatever for this he kidnapped several
girls including Claire but each of his
experiments failed when Brian got to
know of this he tried to warn Mary but
he ended up dying at the hands of Bitner
as well after this the evil Professor
changed his name and started working at
the school so that he could get personal
records of the students when he finally
discovered that Veronica is a February
29th he planned to use her for spectral
absolute nonsense it turns out that bner
was the one who placed the gun in Kirk's
locker and called Anna for an interview
back to the present as Kirk tries to
contact the police Bitner arrives from
behind and knock knocks him out he then
buries the poor guy alive after this he
returns to the special room where
Veronica is staying she is still unaware
that the guy wants to kill her however
when she gets a cut on her finger she
remembers that she had a vision of the
same thing she then puts two and two
together and realizes that the Visions
were trying to warn her which means that
Bitner is a red flag scared she tries to
run away but the evil guy catches up to
her he is about to finish her off but
just then Veronica's dad appears which
distracts bit her for a moment taking
advantage of this opportunity she hits
him with one of her skates and runs
outside however he once again catches up
to her and tries to strangle her when
there's nowhere to go Veronica breaks
the ice beneath him causing both of them
to plummet into the freezing water but
even there the evil guy continues to
strangle her he is about to kill her but
right then Brian's Remnant arrives and
frees Veronica simultaneously the
remnant of Mary also appears and drags
Bitner down down finally killing him in
the aftermath Veronica reaches the
surface but she is too weak to rise up
fortunately Kirk arrives just in time
and saves her it is revealed that when
he was under the ground on the verge of
death his father's Remnant showed up and
dug him out subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching